hello everybody and welcome back fraid
apparently I am I got it
theater is locked kid apparently I don't
have an inventory they lock he's missing
two DS door
how strange stateõs burn care chair one
of these doors that was oh that it no
flashlight
right
using bam using me nothing about it
maybe I need to find another door can
also be
okay well this isn't in Swedish let's
see
akka [ __ ] okay edu DHEC SAP to cute
particular the to kill you mere livin me
dick we gave everything back here my bow
is Sirica gee mister occasion [ __ ]
gigantic abou bricking the kaffir latina
foo kg Luka are you together me okay
I just okay there we go get me out here
[Music]
who's knocking ah someone blew up a 3
being a salad
don't get up
Avenue
ah ah ah what I told you nothing it up
[Music]
okay
that's normal
got it see a bleedin bloody thing
damn I good to be locked I need to find
another way personnel aren't I a person
ok more batteries but no flashlight I
don't know if I missed a flashlight or
something
what don't get up oh hello door ok don't
waste battery
I got chills running up and down my
spine you are trapped oh no I got a
flashlight and now I can oh oh oh it's
fine the curtain oh why is there blood
or was I very manic this was the room I
couldn't see what I was doing pills
don't need pills really there we oh come
on
Oh what the heck my my show then
there must have been some place that I
needed to go that was too dark to
explore or I didn't see what I needed
Wow guess I'm lost already oh well too
bad I guess I'll just have to end this
let's play here okay where did I see
thee I remember seeing a big you know
what I saw ladders
okay nothing here everything can't go up
can't go down alright it must have been
some way here because I remember seeing
through the window that there was a
system like Oh
a stairway outside or something you look
at this signs too much science
top shelf no not here barely explored
okay maybe in here there was a window
that no no hell no hell doesn't is oh oh
no did I just run out of flashlight
batteries forever
okay well be the monster in hiding in
here
[Music]
she lost this early
as I said before the being Ross bridge
I've already been in here now magic tool
toilet is gonna take me on another chair
there's nothing I must oh right here
okay right here come on it's right there
how else do I get through I am out of
batteries that's bad it does recharge
well how the how the bleedin bloody
looting bloody see it it's out there
what do I do about that
okay there was this huh lost all right
Oh false alarm it must be some other way
through here missing there what I see
planks the door is locked
gotta me so gotta me I missed something
big something important big and
important
I just
idiot stupid I can't do anything right
you're are you got up yeah you're just
giving me time to get brave again I got
my daily injection
[Music]
got everything
I hear a draft are these open they're
not are they that would they are ah dang
it that's something that's something
that's something there's no ground aha
yeah there we go okay making progress
yeah all right the best hobbies ah come
on murder
I just swim in my own
[Music]
gonna nice I'm angry huh
yeah and then yeah yeah yeah okay come
out of batteries
damn okay up here
a lot of no what the hell
okay some sort of map but what that
maybe that map needs to tell me
something for you in the hospital but I
basically explored every inch of the
hospital
memorize it
inject it into your brain
No
must be something about something
important I'm very very
hello invisible ceiling a million walk
give me your seats maybe I'm supposed to
okay that was that to get back down
there
okay one snap read the map now aha there
we are
ha no but either way there's something
up
aha how do I get up there
oh we're here yes yeah
breaking-and-entering favorite I don't
like any crimes when he's trying to
passion oh wait
all crimes are bad don't commit crimes
let me out let me know I'm an idiot
battery
[Music]
that's normal I should not touch that
talky touch touch parching I'm touching
it what are you gonna do about it
Paul little kid huh Kiwi coconut face
madam oh I should not touch it that
I touched it okay I reloaded but I
didn't realize that I was out of time
anyway so thank you guys so much for
watching I really do appreciate it I'm
like let's play besides lost that's me
you wouldn't watch my videos if you
didn't expect me a lot babies - thank
you guys skins and I will see you in the
next one bye bye